Most people think Tourette's means swearing. In reality, about 95% of people with Tourette's don't swear at all. So why is one of the most misunderstood neurodevelopmental conditions become defined by a symptom that most people never experience? I'm Dr. Marianne Trent and today I'm joined by fellow clinical psychologist Dr Jason Kodner as we attempt to separate myth from reality. We're exploring the impact that Tourette's can have on everyday life as well as exploring the treatments and support that can help.
大多数人认为妥瑞氏症意味着说脏话。实际上，约95%的妥瑞氏症患者根本不会说脏话。那么，为什么这种最被误解的神经发育障碍之一，会被大多数人从未经历过的症状所定义呢？我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，今天我邀请了临床心理学家同事杰森·科德纳博士，我们将尝试去伪存真。我们将探讨妥瑞氏症对日常生活的影响，以及可以提供帮助的治疗和支持。
Hi, welcome along to psychology actually. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent, a qualified clinical psychologist. I'm joined here today by a fellow qualified clincyc. Hi, Jason. Please do introduce yourself. Hi, my name's Dr Jason Kodner, and I'm the principal clinical psychologist at the Northamptonshire Healthcare NHS Trust, and I currently work in the adult ADHD Autum and Tourette Service.
嗨，欢迎来到“心理学其实”。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。今天我邀请了一位同样合格的临床心理学家同事。嗨，杰森。请自我介绍一下。嗨，我叫杰森·科德纳博士，是北安普敦郡医疗国民保健署（NHS）的首席临床心理学家，目前在成人多动症、自闭症和妥瑞氏症服务部门工作。
Thank you, beautiful. And yeah, it was having done an episode with one of your colleagues previously that made me have a little look on your trust website. And I realised that your service existed. And I thought, that's not something we've ever covered on this podcast. So could you tell us a little bit about what Tourette's is? Yes, so our trust and our team has been in existence of course for nearly 20. years now, 20 plus years and we've always done assessments for Tourette's in that time. As a condition,
谢谢你，亲爱的。是的，之前和你的一位同事做过一期节目后，我浏览了你们信托基金的网站，才意识到你们有这项服务。我想，这在我们的播客中从未涉及过。那么你能告诉我们妥瑞氏症是什么吗？好的，我们的信托基金和团队已经存在近20年了，甚至超过20年，在这期间我们一直进行妥瑞氏症的评估。作为一种疾病，
Tourette's is a neurodevelopmental condition. So what that means is it usually starts in childhood and often continues on into adulthood. And it's characterized often by both motor and physical ticks. They have to occur both together so it can't just be vocal and it can't just be motor ticks. It's got to be both sets of presentation together, really. And then starting in childhood, not better explained by something else. And then once we do the assessment bit, if all the conditions are met, then we would usually give a diagnosis of Touretti.
妥瑞氏症是一种神经发育障碍。这意味着它通常始于童年，并经常持续到成年。它的特征通常是运动抽动和发声抽动。它们必须同时出现，不能只有发声抽动，也不能只有运动抽动。这两种表现必须同时存在，而且始于童年，不能用其他原因更好地解释。一旦我们完成了评估，如果所有条件都满足，我们通常会给出妥瑞氏症的诊断。
Thank you. So I've already learned something because I'm sure when I last learned about it was working with tick disorder, which I understand is a bit different. We were we were kind of grouping as a neurological disorder but it's now it's kind of it's now thought of as neurodevelopmental Jason yes yeah well it's I suppose if you want to get really boy so in the DSM-5 so the Diagnostical Statistical Manual version 5 which is the American sort of manual for diagnosing mental health and neurodevelopmental disorders it falls in their new they're currently in their neurodevelopmental category but
谢谢。我已经学到了一些东西，因为我上次了解它时，还是在处理抽动障碍，我理解那有点不同。我们当时把它归类为神经系统疾病，但现在它被认为是神经发育障碍，杰森，是这样吗？是的，如果你想说得非常专业，在《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》第5版（DSM-5）中，也就是美国用于诊断心理健康和神经发育障碍的手册，它被归入他们目前的神经发育类别，但是
before 2013, there wasn't a category for neurodevelopmental disorders. It was, I think it was disease of childhood or starting in the developmental period. So the neurodevelopmental bit comes from the DSM-5 and I think it's just their umbrella term for all the conditions that started in childhood and that might continue on into adulthood. I see. Thank you for that clarification. And, you know, I think Tourette's gets misunderstood. because I don't think people realise how much of an impact it can have on your life. I know there's been lots of stuff in the media since the Netflix film called I Swear, which is amazing. I've watched it, really, really interesting.
在2013年之前，还没有“神经发育障碍”这个类别。我想它当时属于“儿童期疾病”或“始于发育期”。所以“神经发育”这个词来自DSM-5，我认为这是他们为所有始于童年并可能持续到成年的疾病所设的统称。我明白了。谢谢你的澄清。而且，我认为妥瑞氏症被误解了，因为我不认为人们意识到它对生活的影响有多大。我知道自从Netflix那部名为《我发誓》（I Swear）的电影上映以来，媒体上有很多相关内容，那部电影很棒。我看过，真的非常有趣。
And I also follow a really great creator called Luke Manton on LinkedIn. If people don't already follow him, I would recommend that because he has Tourette's himself. So I feel like I've learned a bit more through both of those. kind of case studies, if you will. But this really can affect people's lives globally, can't it? Yeah, yeah. And I think with the Tourette's bit,
我还关注了领英上的一位很棒的创作者卢克·曼顿。如果人们还没关注他，我推荐大家关注，因为他本人就患有妥瑞氏症。所以我觉得通过这两个案例研究，我学到了更多。但这确实会从全球范围内影响人们的生活，不是吗？是的，是的。关于妥瑞氏症，
it's been a condition for a very long time. It has relatively recently changed its name. So previously in the DSM and the ICD, which is the sort of European and World Health Organisation's manual for, classifications, it used to be known as the Giles de la Tourette, I think is how you pronounce it. And that's where the Tourette bit comes on, so the Jiles bit, bit, and just stuck with that's bit really. So yeah, I think it's prevalent across the world.
它作为一种疾病已经存在很长时间了。它最近才改名。之前在DSM和ICD（欧洲和世界卫生组织的手册）中，它被称为“吉尔斯·德拉·妥瑞特”（Giles de la Tourette），我想发音是这样的。这就是“妥瑞”（Tourette）这个词的由来，所以“吉尔斯”部分被去掉了，只留下了“妥瑞”。所以是的，我认为它在世界各地都很普遍。
So lots of people will present with that. I think the bits that can make it really difficult is because the interventions for it can be quite difficult to put together, definitely outside of sort of Western civilization sort of thing really often then nothing gets nothing sort of happens with it you just get ostracized often because it's uncontrollable but it's involuntary responses in terms of the vocal ticks and the motor ticks and because they are involuntary sometimes they can be causing offense they can cause difficulties they can cause a lot of pain for the individual as well, depending on the type of ticks that they might have as well. So a lot of physical pain can come about from some of them.
所以很多人都会表现出这种症状。我认为让它变得非常困难的部分原因是，针对它的干预措施很难整合，特别是在西方文明之外，通常什么都不会发生，你只会因为无法控制而受到排斥。但就发声抽动和运动抽动而言，这些是不自主的反应。因为它们是不自主的，有时会引起冒犯，造成困难，也会给个人带来很多痛苦，这取决于他们可能有的抽动类型。所以其中一些会导致很多身体上的痛苦。
Some can be quite extreme for the person's experiencing them as well, really. Yeah. So there has been a high profile example of that recently, hasn't there, with the, I think it was John was the name of the person that was featured in, I swear. And he went, I think was it the BAFTAs or the Golden Globes or the Oscars? It was some big award ceremony. Some big awards were there. I've been in the news. And I think everybody in the audience was warned. You know, we do have the star of the show here today who does have Tourette's.
对经历这些的人来说，有些可能非常极端。是的。最近有一个备受瞩目的例子，对吧？我想是《我发誓》中出现的那个人叫约翰。他去了，我想是英国电影学院奖（BAFTAs）、金球奖还是奥斯卡奖？那是某个大型颁奖典礼。一些大型颁奖典礼。我一直在新闻里看到。我想观众中的每个人都被警告了。你知道，我们今天确实有节目的主角在这里，他确实患有妥瑞氏症。
And so if you do hear anything, then please know that that's not someone purposefully causing offence. But of course, Tourette's almost works with kind of the subconscious and kind of, praise on the thing that is the least appropriate thing to say sometimes, and that will come out. And I think there was some people of kind of an ethnic, diverse background on the stage, and then he said something racist that then everybody heard. And I think the real for Aure was not about necessarily the person. It wasn't about John. It was about the fact that the, I think it was, the BBC, were broadcasting it on a delay and hadn't chose to then bleep out the expletives in that. So that was the bit that really did make the headlines. And that can be
所以如果你听到什么，请知道那不是有人故意引起冒犯。但当然，妥瑞氏症几乎是在潜意识中运作，有时会利用最不恰当的话语，然后脱口而出。我想当时舞台上有一些多元文化背景的人，然后他说了一些种族主义的话，每个人都听到了。我认为真正的愤怒不一定是因为那个人。不是关于约翰，而是关于BBC，我想是BBC，他们在广播时有延迟，却选择没有消掉那些脏话。所以这才是真正登上头条的部分。这可能
difficult, can't it for people? If they are saying things they don't mean and that they haven't got control of, but people will make that kind of cognitive judgment or just a reactive judgment. Yeah, about what's going on. And it's and yeah, I think it was the BBC had not, or whichever a broadcaster it was at the time had not chosen to bleep out, I guess, that particular bit if they had put it on a delay. I'm not, didn't be too much about it at the time because sometimes there's a lot of free-or and sometimes it's just easy to let the dust settle and then go back and have a look. So I'm not sure how much they were actually putting a delay on. I think that was one of the criticisms of the BBC's all it would have been more helpful but anyway, so yeah,
很困难，不是吗？如果他们说的话不是本意，而且无法控制，但人们会做出那种认知判断或仅仅是反应性判断。是的，关于正在发生的事情。而且，是的，我想是BBC没有，或者当时无论是哪个广播公司，都没有选择消掉那一部分，如果他们确实设置了延迟的话。我当时对这件事了解不多，因为有时会有很多喧嚣，有时让尘埃落定后再回头看会更容易。所以我不太确定他们当时是否真的设置了延迟。我认为那是对BBC的批评之一，否则会更有帮助，但无论如何，所以是的，
so often with inappropriate language are we saying in terms of that it's, uh, particularly the swearing side of things and saying things that might be offensive or upset into other people. It's a relatively tiny proportion of people with Tourette's that actually can struggle with that aspect of how they might express their vocal tics. But I think because it's the most shocking and media ex-sensationalized, that's the stuff that people tend to associate Tourette with in particular, that even though, you know, of, you know, 100 people, you know, five to 10 might have some difficulties around expressing in terms of that. But that's the focus it tends to be in terms of that bit really. But it can be a really difficult experience for the person with Tourette's themselves, because more often than not, they're just as horrified that they're using that
所以通常对于不恰当的语言，我们是在说，特别是说脏话方面，以及说出可能冒犯或让其他人不安的话。实际上，只有极小比例的妥瑞氏症患者会在这方面感到挣扎。但我认为因为这是最令人震惊和媒体最感官化的部分，所以人们倾向于将妥瑞氏症与此联系起来，尽管你知道，100个人里，可能有5到10个人在表达方面有一些困难。但这往往是人们关注的焦点。但这对妥瑞氏症患者本人来说可能是一种非常困难的经历，因为他们往往对自己使用那种
language, but not feeling able to control, not able to stop themselves from expressing that because it doesn't, you know, I said it's an involuntary sound that comes out, it's involuntary words, involuntary movement. So it can make it very difficult. And I think one of the aspects of the film shows is just how isolating that can be, because often you then are aware of how other people react. So you tend not to go into situations. You tend not to put yourself out there. You tend not to interact with others because the worry about saying or offending something, somebody or doing something can make it really difficult. And that can fail. really lonely if you feel the people around you don't understand or aren't accepting that
语言感到同样震惊，但却无法控制，无法阻止自己表达出来，因为它，你知道，我说过这是一种不自主发出的声音，是不自主的词汇，不自主的动作。所以这会让人非常困难。我认为这部电影展示的其中一个方面就是这有多么孤立，因为你通常会意识到别人的反应。所以你倾向于不去参加某些场合。你倾向于不让自己走出去。你倾向于不与他人互动，因为担心说错话或冒犯某人，或者做错事会让人非常困难。如果你觉得周围的人不理解或不接受，那会让人感到非常孤独，
there are things that are going to happen that are outside of your control. Yeah, and it's making me think about, I think, the first person I'd ever learned of who had this is I think I was maybe studying psychology at the time, I think it was late 90s, early 2000s, it was Pete from Big Brother. Does that ring a bell for you? And we got it vaguely, yes. I remember Big Brother, but yeah, yeah. So Nikki Graham, it was that year. Ricky Graham and Pete and Pete, I think some of Pete's ticks would be when he became overstimulated, he'd sort of shout, shout white goods, and like that was his thing, like as in, you know, like your washing machine or your tumble dryer. So not necessarily going to offend anybody,
有些事情是超出你控制范围的。是的，这让我想起，我想，我认识的第一个患有此病的人，我想我当时可能在学习心理学，大概是90年代末、2000年代初，是《老大哥》（Big Brother）里的皮特。你对他有印象吗？我们隐约记得，是的。我记得《老大哥》，但是的，是的。所以尼基·格雷厄姆，那是那一年。瑞奇·格雷厄姆和皮特，我想皮特的一些抽动是在他过度刺激时，他会大喊“白色家电”，就像那是他的标志，就像，你知道，比如你的洗衣机或滚筒烘干机。所以不一定会冒犯任何人，
but, you know, I think sometimes Tourette's gets a kind of reputation as being funny or humorous. And I think that's tricky, isn't it? Because you then aren't necessarily seeing the impact this has on your family, on your friends. on your being able to have a relationship, on your being able to work and hold down a job. Yeah, yeah. And I think that's definitely been one of the, and I suppose unfortunate media portrayals. And for many years, there were jokes
但是，你知道，我认为有时妥瑞氏症被认为是有趣或幽默的。我认为这很棘手，不是吗？因为你并没有看到这对你的家庭、朋友、你维持关系的能力、你工作和保住工作的能力所产生的影响。是的，是的。我认为这绝对是其中之一，我想是不幸的媒体刻画。多年来，有很多笑话
and a lot of sort of humour around people who might express ticks or that somehow it would be funny to have that difficulty in the expression. in that really. I, on one hand, I think that's got better to some extent, although I think it is still a really big issue. And as we can see from what happened with John at the ceremony, there's still quite a lot of misunderstanding. There's still a lot of different difficulties around how do we support people with Tourette's when they're in a situation that is live, that is going to be broadcast, where there is a high likelihood, given And it was John's difficulties in particular that things that might offend or upset other people might be broadcast and how do we protect both the person with Tourette's and how do we lessen
以及很多关于可能表现出抽动的人的幽默，或者认为有这种表达困难会很有趣。一方面，我认为这在某种程度上有所好转，尽管我认为这仍然是一个非常大的问题。正如我们从约翰在颁奖典礼上发生的事情所看到的那样，仍然存在很多误解。在他们处于直播、将被广播的情况下，如何支持妥瑞氏症患者，仍然存在很多不同的困难，考虑到约翰的困难，可能会冒犯或让其他人不安的事情可能会被广播，我们如何保护妥瑞氏症患者，以及我们如何减轻
for some of the impact that might happen really in terms of having that delayed on and then maybe being able to bleep out some bits or cut away or just having a little bit of, okay, what are we going to do if, how are we going to manage, how are we going to support John? Because I suppose that was a bit we didn't hear a lot about is actually he would have been absolutely horrified and I think he did release a statement a few days later about how upsetting it is and for him as well to be using language that as a individual he absolutely abhors and wouldn't use but because of the Tourette's and the involuntary nature of what's happening and then having that not only using that language but broadcasting it live across
可能发生的一些影响，比如设置延迟，然后也许能够消掉一些部分，或者切换画面，或者只是有一点，好吧，我们要怎么做，我们要怎么管理，我们要怎么支持约翰？因为我想那是我们没有听到很多的部分，实际上他当时肯定会感到非常震惊，我想他几天后确实发表了一份声明，关于使用他个人绝对厌恶且不会使用的语言是多么令人不安，但因为妥瑞氏症和正在发生的事情的不自主性质，然后不仅使用了那种语言，还向
the millions of people who are watching it yeah I'm not sure how much support John had then got from you know others and the BBC see after that. Yeah, that's a really good, really good point. Speaking clinically, you know, sometimes I will sit and giggle with clients and I did when I was in the NHS as well, because so much of it is about having a good relationship and also being a human. I mean, does stuff crop up that happens with people in your clinic where it is funny? Or are you always having to kind of suppress that to be very serious and respectful, Jason? I'm sorry, that's a really awkward. No, no, no, no. I think it's a really helpful one.
数百万观看它的人直播，是的，我不确定约翰在那之后从其他人（你知道，BBC）那里得到了多少支持。是的，这是一个非常好的观点。从临床角度来说，你知道，有时我会和客户一起咯咯笑，我在NHS时也这样做过，因为这很大程度上是关于建立良好的关系，也是关于做一个人类。我的意思是，在你的诊所里，人们身上会发生有趣的事情吗？还是你总是不得不压抑这种情绪，表现得非常严肃和尊重，杰森？抱歉，这是一个非常尴尬的问题。不，不，不，不。我认为这是一个非常有帮助的问题。
It's definitely thinking our clinic, so we run a weekly clinic with one of the few NHS trusts that does work with adults with Tourette's, most services, and there aren't many, to be honest, tend to focus with children, but we work with adults. And you can have a really, it's not sure fun's right word, but it can be really liberating, I think, often for clients to talk about some of the things they struggle with, but also some of the situations that have been humorous for them in terms of the Tourette's and how that might have manifest. And yes, there are other elements where it's really uncomfortable and they dislike having them and they cause them a lot of difficulties.
这绝对是在思考我们的诊所，所以我们每周开设一个诊所，是少数几个与妥瑞氏症成年人合作的NHS信托基金之一，大多数服务（老实说，并不多）倾向于关注儿童，但我们与成年人合作。我认为对于客户来说，谈论他们挣扎的一些事情，以及妥瑞氏症如何表现的一些对他们来说幽默的情况，通常是非常解放的，我不确定“有趣”是不是正确的词。是的，还有其他元素，他们感到非常不舒服，他们不喜欢有这些症状，这些症状给他们造成了很多困难。
is, but there are occasions, I think, where we've interacted with clients and they've been able to talk about the humour side of things when that's happened. There might only be brief moments for them, but there have been occasions, I think, where sometimes expressing those things can be a moment of lightness for them rather than the sort of constant worry and anxiety, particularly when they're outside, what they might feel is their safe space, or often when they're at home, that's usually the time when that sort of happens. It's less likely from what we've seen in our clinics where clients will talk about or experience that outside of being in their safe space or with people who know them really well. Yeah, thank you. And, you know, just kind of segueing back to Luke
但是，我认为在某些情况下，我们与客户互动，当这种情况发生时，他们能够谈论幽默的一面。对他们来说可能只是短暂的时刻，但我认为确实有这样的场合，有时表达这些事情对他们来说可能是一个轻松的时刻，而不是持续的担忧和焦虑，特别是当他们在他们认为的安全空间之外时，或者通常当他们在家里时，那通常是这种情况发生的时候。根据我们在诊所的观察，客户在安全空间之外或与非常了解他们的人在一起时，谈论或经历这种情况的可能性较小。是的，谢谢。而且，你知道，只是转回到卢克·曼顿，
Manton, I really love his work because he, when he was given the diagnosis as an adult, was almost sort of told, oh, this is how it's going to be now. You know, you might as well, get familiar with your benefits office because you'll likely you'll never work again, you know. That's not always the case. And certainly in his case, he speaks very publicly. So I've never, I've never been his psychologist. I'm not, I just follow him on social and admire his work. So he talks very publicly about his experiences and raising awareness of this, but has then built a business, which is very successful. So it is possible, but it obviously, it does put barriers, especially with employed work, it can put barriers in place for sufferers,
我真的很喜欢他的工作，因为他在成年后被诊断出患有此病时，几乎被告知，哦，现在情况就是这样了。你知道，你最好熟悉一下你的福利办公室，因为你可能再也无法工作了，你知道。情况并非总是如此。当然在他的案例中，他非常公开地发言。所以我从来没有做过他的心理学家。我不是，我只是在社交媒体上关注他并钦佩他的工作。所以他非常公开地谈论他的经历并提高人们对这一点的认识，但随后建立了一家非常成功的企业。所以这是可能的，但这显然确实设置了障碍，特别是在雇佣工作中，它确实会给患者设置障碍，
can't it, Jason? Yeah, yeah. And I think depending on who and where you might have got your assessment and what's happening in terms of that. I know that Tourette's Action, which is the national charity for Tourette's in the UK, does a huge amount of work in terms of both training clinicians who might be interested in doing the diagnostic work, but also in terms of doing some of the intervention work around supporting people,
不是吗，杰森？是的，是的。而且我认为这取决于你在哪里以及从谁那里得到了评估，以及这方面正在发生什么。我知道“妥瑞氏症行动”（Tourette's Action），也就是英国的妥瑞氏症国家慈善机构，在培训可能对进行诊断工作感兴趣的临床医生方面做了大量工作，同时也做了一些围绕支持人们的干预工作，
with Tourette's to help them develop a measure of control about helping them better understand their Tourette's, what's going on, and developing strategies for helping lessening some of that impact. Now, unfortunately, we don't have a cure, so we can't stop Tourette's for people. But there is often throughout somebody's lifespan with Tourette's a process of what we call waxing and waning. So sometimes the ticks are really prevalent and other times they're not as round as much. and then something can happen and trigger that. So it could be a stress reaction, it could be anxiety, worry, all these can help increase that bit as well. And I think when the workplace element to that then can make it really difficult
患有妥瑞氏症的人，帮助他们发展一定程度的控制力，帮助他们更好地理解他们的妥瑞氏症，了解正在发生的事情，并制定策略来帮助减轻这种影响。现在，不幸的是，我们没有治愈方法，所以我们无法为人们停止妥瑞氏症。但在某人患有妥瑞氏症的一生中，通常会有一个我们称之为“起伏”（waxing and waning）的过程。所以有时抽动非常普遍，而其他时候则没有那么多。然后可能会发生一些事情并触发它。所以这可能是压力反应，可能是焦虑、担忧，所有这些都有助于增加那一部分。而且我认为当工作场所的因素加入其中时，会使它变得非常困难，
to either find a workplace that's accommodating or understanding enough in terms of that bit really. But absolutely Tourette's in and of itself doesn't have to be a barrier to finding work really. I think definitely more so with the Equality Act and reasonable adjustments and just a, even a small amount of understanding and just knowing what the myths are around Tourette's and knowing what the reality is, I think can help people pursue that life of maybe wanting to work and pursue things I'm really interested in. Yeah, and I'm always very curious about inclusion and having conversations around inclusion, You know, I've had a podcast episode with someone that is registered blind, has a guide dog and is a trainee psychologist, you know, someone that uses a wheelchair, someone that's got kind of limb difference.
要么找到一个足够包容或理解的工作场所，就那一点而言。但绝对地，妥瑞氏症本身并不一定是寻找工作的障碍。我认为随着《平等法案》和合理的调整，以及仅仅是一点点的理解，了解围绕妥瑞氏症的神话是什么，了解现实是什么，我认为可以帮助人们追求那种可能想要工作和追求我真正感兴趣的事情的生活。是的，我总是对包容性以及围绕包容性进行对话非常好奇，你知道，我曾有一期播客采访过一位注册盲人，有导盲犬，是一名实习心理学家，你知道，还有使用轮椅的人，有肢体差异的人。
Like, do you or could you imagine a time where we had, you know, a qualified HCPC psychologist with Touret. Or maybe there was one already and I'm just not aware of them. Yes, it's a short answer. We could. We may, as I said, we may already have in terms of that. I think the bits around managing, I suppose, the different presentations of Tourette's that might occur in terms of that. I think, yes, anecdotally, I know that we've, as a clinic, we've had other clinicians
就像，你是否可以想象或者你能想象有一天，我们有，你知道，一位合格的HCPC心理学家患有妥瑞氏症。或者也许已经有一位了，我只是不知道他们。是的，简短的回答是。我们可以。我们可能，正如我所说，我们可能已经有了。我认为围绕管理，我想，妥瑞氏症可能出现的不同表现，就那一点而言。我认为，是的，根据轶事，我知道我们，作为一个诊所，我们有其他临床医生
who've come through and wanting to really get a better understanding and trying to manage how their Tourette's and their ticks might present so that they can go on. and do clinical work in terms of that bit. And they were quite keen to try and manage that so that when they were interacting with the client, they felt that they did have somewhat more of a measure of control about when they might express those ticks, really. So yeah, I would not be surprised if we already did have
他们走过来，想要真正更好地理解并试图管理他们的妥瑞氏症和他们的抽动可能如何表现，以便他们可以继续进行临床工作。他们非常热衷于尝试管理这一点，以便当他们与客户互动时，他们觉得他们对何时可能表达这些抽动有更多的控制权，真的。所以是的，如果我发现我们已经有了一位患有诊断的客户心理学家，我不会感到惊讶。
a client psychologist out there who already did have a diagnosis. Amazing, it might be a case of watch this space. But if that is you, please make yourself known to us because we would love to be able to see how that is for you. So, you know, not to be too bleak, but you've said there's no cure. Speaking as a psychologist, is there, I don't know, will formulation help? Is there any particular approach or method that can help someone to control this or make a bit of a difference for them?
太棒了，这可能是一个“敬请期待”的情况。但如果那是你，请让我们知道，因为我们很想看看这对你来说是怎样的。所以，你知道，不要太悲观，但你说没有治愈方法。作为一名心理学家，有没有，我不知道，构思（formulation）会有帮助吗？有没有什么特定的方法或手段可以帮助某人控制这一点或为他们带来一点改变？
Yes, is a short answer. So there's two, well, I'm supposed to, there's several approaches, I think, that can be really helpful. The first one is really understanding what Tourette's is and how it might impact on somebody. And I think once people who do have a diagnosis of it, or might have that presentation, I think when they really begin to understand and get a sense of what that means both for them and how the Sajima are, I think those, the bits that can be really helpful in terms and empowering them to know what they can do and what they might need some more support with around that. And then once they've got the diagnosis being assessed, going into the intervention side of stuff, there's no nice guidelines for Tourette's at the moment.
是的，简短的回答是。所以有两种，好吧，我想是，有几种方法，我认为，可以非常有帮助。第一种是真正理解什么是妥瑞氏症以及它可能如何影响某人。而且我认为一旦那些确实有诊断的人，或者可能有这种表现的人，当他们真正开始理解并感受到这对他们意味着什么，以及Sajima（注：此处疑为口误，应指症状）是什么时，我认为那些，可以非常有帮助的部分，并赋予他们权力，让他们知道他们能做什么，以及他们可能需要在哪些方面得到更多支持。一旦他们得到了诊断并进行了评估，进入干预方面，目前还没有针对妥瑞氏症的NICE指南。
So there's no guidelines around what assessment should like. There's no guidelines around what intervention should look like. There are, however, some what they call the nice appraisal stuff. So there's some, I think because of AI and the massive advances in technology, they're, the technology appraisal side of Nice has been working a little bit faster. So sometimes they'll agree a technology, but they haven't got a formal guidance. So for Tourette's, for children, so under 17s, there are some appraisal technologies that say that comprehensive behaviour intervention for Tourette's, which is a, I want to say, cognitive behavioural
所以没有关于评估应该是什么样子的指南。没有关于干预应该是什么样子的指南。然而，有一些他们称之为NICE评估的东西。所以有一些，我认为因为人工智能和技术的巨大进步，NICE的技术评估方面工作得稍微快一点。所以有时他们会同意一项技术，但他们没有正式的指导。所以对于妥瑞氏症，对于儿童，也就是17岁以下的人，有一些评估技术说，针对妥瑞氏症的综合行为干预，这是一种，我想说，认知行为
boast one, but it's a behavioural boast intervention, which usually, you run to about eight to 12 sessions. There's sort of two main umbrella ones into there. There's what's known as habit reversal and exposure response in terms of the two main ones in terms of helping people to understand what's going on, really. So in terms of the intervention side of stuff, if you are somebody who wants to explore that, there is what's known as a pre-monetary urge. So most people or a lot of people with experienced Tourette's have,
增强型，但它是一种行为增强干预，通常，你进行大约8到12次疗程。其中主要有两种伞形方法。有两种被称为习惯逆转和暴露反应，这是帮助人们理解正在发生的事情的两种主要方法。所以就干预方面而言，如果你是一个想要探索这一点的人，有一种被称为“前驱冲动”（pre-monitory urge）。所以大多数人或很多经历过妥瑞氏症的人有，
a, I suppose a sensation that their ticks are coming on. And one of the things that both of those interventions looks at is to help people begin to recognize and understand when those premonitory urges are about to occur and what they then can do to help sit with that and then help them to lessen that the next step, which will often be expressing their ticks really. And when we talk with clients in the clinic, we tend to think of it in terms of it's a bit like having an itch and then you scratch the itch. So the itch would be the premonitory urge and then the tick would be you scratching it. So in the moment it does seem to feel like it gives you some relief from the urge, but by doing the tick, you're increasing the likelihood that the next time you have that
一种，我想是一种感觉，他们的抽动即将到来。而这两种干预措施所关注的事情之一是帮助人们开始识别和理解这些前驱冲动何时即将发生，以及他们随后可以做什么来帮助与那种感觉共处，然后帮助他们减轻下一步，这通常是表达他们的抽动。当我们与诊所的客户交谈时，我们倾向于认为这有点像有一个痒点，然后你去抓那个痒点。所以痒点就是前驱冲动，然后抽动就是你去抓它。所以在当下，它确实感觉好像让你从冲动中得到了一些缓解，但通过做抽动，你增加了下一次你有那个
premonit urge, you're more likely then to act on the tick. And then what the habit reversal and the ERP is looking at is trying to help people to sit longer with the premonetary urge until it fades so that you don't express the tick and there's got sort of two different ways of sort of exploring that with somebody. I see, there's almost some parallel between kind of how we might work with OCD as well then, like trying to tolerate that distress a little bit longer before you take that action. Yes, yeah. And I, and often there is quite a somewhat of an overlap between Touret behaviours and possible OCD. So often when we work in clinic and we do work, we're trying to separate out what might be ticks and what might be an OCD behaviour in terms of some of the things we do really.
前驱冲动时，你更有可能采取抽动行为的可能性。然后习惯逆转和ERP所关注的是试图帮助人们更长时间地与前驱冲动共处，直到它消退，这样你就不会表达抽动，并且有几种不同的方式来与某人探索这一点。我明白了，那几乎与我们处理强迫症（OCD）的方式有一些相似之处，比如试图在采取行动之前更长时间地忍受那种痛苦。是的，是的。而且，通常妥瑞氏症行为和可能的强迫症之间确实有某种重叠。所以通常当我们在诊所工作时，我们试图区分什么是抽动，什么是强迫症行为，就我们所做的一些事情而言。
And I think that sense of helping people to, I suppose, grow their hope that actually just because you might have a diagnosis of threats doesn't mean that there isn't interventions. There is things that could be really supportive and helpful. I know for our service we tend to follow the European guidelines around ticks and Tourette's because there is some European guidelines, there's just no UK ones at the moment, or nice ones in terms of guidance and I think it's the first, second and third line of interventions is more behaviourally based. There is a little bit where they will talk about it's possible that some medications might be helpful, but it's very much a sort of.
而且我认为那种帮助人们，我想，增长他们的希望的感觉，实际上仅仅因为你可能有一个妥瑞氏症的诊断，并不意味着没有干预措施。有一些事情可以是非常支持和有帮助的。我知道对于我们的服务，我们倾向于遵循欧洲关于抽动和妥瑞氏症的指南，因为有一些欧洲指南，目前只是没有英国的，或者NICE的指导，而且我认为第一、第二和第三线干预措施更多是基于行为的。有一点他们会谈到，某些药物可能是有帮助的，但这非常像是一种
of an off-licence prescription if that happens and you would need a usually a psychiatrist or a neuropsychiatrist who had a good sense of an understanding of that and they will just trial and error it to help manage some of those behaviors when they're occurring really. Yeah, thank you. That's a really helpful overview. And I know people are always thinking about, well, who is more likely to have this? Is there anything that makes that, you know, I know when we're looking at something like fibromyalgia or kind of polycystic recoveries or even kind of things like migraines, there's actually evidence that shows us that people with higher kind of adverse childhood scales scores for adverse events in childhood are more
超说明书用药，如果发生这种情况，你通常需要一位对这方面有很好理解的精神科医生或神经精神科医生，他们会通过反复试验来帮助管理其中一些行为，当它们发生时。是的，谢谢。这是一个非常有帮助的概述。而且我知道人们总是会思考，谁更容易患上这种病？有没有什么因素导致，你知道，我知道当我们观察像纤维肌痛或多囊卵巢综合征，甚至像偏头痛这样的事情时，实际上有证据表明，童年时期有较高不良童年经历评分的人，
likely to get those conditions. Is that a parallel for Tourette's or is it kind of just random? To some extent it varies. There isn't a massive amount of research in Tourette's action. Again, They do quite a lot of work in this area and they fund research into this area as well. There are some elements that are looking at terms of Tourette's and how, whether they're particular populations that it might be more occurring in. I suppose in terms of that bit where Tourette's and I suppose neurodevelopmental conditions in general really is that you typically seem to see if somebody's like, to present with Tourette's, they're likely to have possibly something else as well.
更有可能患上这些疾病。妥瑞氏症也是这样吗，还是仅仅是随机的？在某种程度上，它各不相同。在“妥瑞氏症行动”中没有大量的研究。同样，他们在这一领域做了很多工作，他们也资助了这一领域的研究。有一些因素正在观察妥瑞氏症，以及是否有特定的群体更容易发生这种情况。我想就那一点而言，妥瑞氏症和神经发育障碍通常确实是，你通常似乎看到，如果某人可能表现出妥瑞氏症，他们很可能也有其他问题。
So that could be a mental health difficulty, so anxiety, mood disorder, possibly OCD, but they also might present with another neurodevelopmental condition. So ADHD is often one that we can sometimes see autism, which is partly why our service tends to work with all three, because there is so much overlapping in terms of what we tend to see in terms of the other difficulties that somebody might present with. Thank you. And there might be a variety of reasons why people are watching or listening to this episode. And one of the options might be that they themselves think they might fulfill, you know, a diagnosis or that someone that they care about. What should someone do if they are, you know, experiencing this almost for the first time or they're trying to join up the dots?
所以这可能是心理健康困难，比如焦虑、情绪障碍、可能的强迫症，但他们也可能表现出另一种神经发育障碍。所以多动症通常是我们有时能看到的，自闭症，这就是为什么我们的服务倾向于与这三者合作，因为我们在某人可能表现出的其他困难方面看到了太多的重叠。谢谢。人们观看或收听这一集可能有各种各样的原因。其中一个选择可能是他们自己认为他们可能符合，你知道，一个诊断，或者他们关心的人。如果有人，你知道，几乎是第一次经历这种情况，或者他们试图把点连起来，他们应该怎么做？
Yeah. Absolutely. Definitely going for GP because most services will require a GP referral. depending on where you are in the country, some services may be done via neurology or newer psychiatry, if you're particularly fortunate to have access to a neurosychologist in your area. But GP is generally the first port of core, really. And I definitely think for adults in terms of the diagnosis,
是的。绝对要去看全科医生（GP），因为大多数服务都需要全科医生转诊。根据你在国家的哪个位置，有些服务可能通过神经科或神经精神科完成，如果你特别幸运，在你的地区有神经心理学家。但全科医生通常是第一站，真的。而且我绝对认为对于成年人的诊断，
but the bits that it would be useful to think back is, has this always been something I've had? So did it start in childhood for you? be that it was present in childhood but maybe it's gone away so sometimes we've seen clients where they may have had Tourette's tick-like behaviour in childhood but it wasn't formally diagnosed or assessed well and when i say that i mean in terms of they might not have done a hour long sort of assessment where they've asked them a range of questions around how often what's it look like what parts of your body does it seem to go which is where we would
但有用的部分是回想一下，这一直是我有的东西吗？所以它是在童年时期为你开始的吗？可能是它在童年时期就存在，但也许它消失了，所以有时我们见过客户，他们可能在童年时期有妥瑞氏症抽动样行为，但它没有被正式诊断或评估得很好，当我这么说时，我的意思是，他们可能没有进行过一小时左右的评估，询问他们一系列关于频率、它看起来是什么样、它似乎影响你身体的哪些部位的问题，这是我们
typically do. But often what we've seen in the notes when people come to us is they might have gone to a healthcare professional, they've noticed the ticks, and they've said they've also got ticks, and that's it. There's like a line or a comment and they've moved on. Some of that might be, I think, because there's historically always been very difficult to have an intervention for that. So often it was just like we've noticed ticks and then they'll move on to what bought the person through really. But definitely as an adult, I think if you're thinking about that might explain some of the things I've struggled with. It's definitely thinking about whether he's present in childhood.
通常会做的。但通常我们在人们来到我们这里时在记录中看到的是，他们可能去看过医疗专业人员，他们注意到了抽动，他们说他们也有抽动，就这样。就像有一行字或评论，然后他们就继续了。其中一些可能，我认为，是因为历史上一直很难对此进行干预。所以通常只是我们注意到了抽动，然后他们会转向让那个人来的原因。但绝对作为成年人，我认为如果你在思考这可能解释了我挣扎的一些事情。绝对要思考它是否在童年时期就存在。
If you're not sure, you don't remember, it's worth asking parents. So sometimes people will talk about or parents will comment about, well, they always seem to have hay fever, even though it wasn't hay fevers. So they sniffed a lot or they seemed to blink a lot, or they had a particular twitch or movement. And as long as there was a vocal bit alongside that, and then if that's persisted for longer than a year, and then as an adult, if you're experiencing those things, then it might be worth having a conversation with the GP around. I think particularly if it causes a problem for you.
如果你不确定，你不记得了，值得问问父母。所以有时人们会谈论或父母会评论，好吧，他们似乎总是患有花粉症，即使那不是花粉症。所以他们嗅了很多，或者他们似乎眨眼很多，或者他们有特定的抽动或动作。只要这旁边有一个发声的部分，然后如果这种情况持续超过一年，然后作为成年人，如果你正在经历这些事情，那么可能值得与全科医生进行一次关于这方面的谈话。我认为特别是如果它给你造成了问题。
For some people, we've had clients who have sort of been referred, but they've said, actually, it's who I am. Yes, it causes problems and it's difficult, but I can manage it, and they don't necessarily want to go on and get an assessment and access intervention. Whereas other clients have said, that actually this is really, really difficult. And I absolutely do need some help and support around managing some of this, even if it's to allow other people, healthcare professionals, workplace,
对于有些人，我们有客户被转诊，但他们说，实际上，这就是我。是的，它造成了问题，这很困难，但我可以管理它，他们不一定想继续进行评估和获得干预。而其他客户说，实际上这真的，真的非常困难。我绝对需要一些帮助和支持来管理其中的一些，即使是为了让其他人，医疗专业人员，工作场所，
to say this is why I struggle in these situations. These are why my behaviours might come across this way. Yeah, and obviously speaking as a qualified psychologist, both of us, we want people to be able to live as full and active life as they would want for themselves or is feasible. And as part of that, people might obviously want to get married, they might want to have children, they might, if they're female, find themselves that they're pregnant, they're expecting. And is, you know, is that something that will take additional consideration for someone with Tourette's? Yeah, so it's not typical, I think, for our service that we have had concerns around safeguarding in terms of maybe the extent of the Tourette's
说这就是为什么我在这些情况下挣扎。这就是为什么我的行为可能看起来是这样。是的，显然作为一名合格的心理学家，我们两个，我们希望人们能够过上他们自己想要的或可行的充实和积极的生活。作为其中的一部分，人们可能显然想结婚，他们可能想生孩子，他们可能，如果他们是女性，发现自己怀孕了，他们正在期待。而且，你知道，这是妥瑞氏症患者需要额外考虑的事情吗？是的，所以，我认为我们的服务通常不会有关于保护方面的担忧，就妥瑞氏症的程度而言
behaviour that might be going on for somebody. Often if there was likely to be a safeguarding inn, I'm saying it's always the case, it would either have been Tourette's that had been present throughout childhood, in which case it wouldn't be come to our service anyway in terms of that bit. I suppose the bits where we've had more of that is more other presentations that might have caused difficulties. So functional neurological disorder in particular, which
可能正在发生的行为。通常如果可能存在保护问题，我不是说总是这样，那要么是妥瑞氏症在整个童年时期一直存在，在这种情况下，无论如何都不会来到我们的服务。我想我们有更多这种情况的部分是其他可能导致困难的表现。所以特别是功能性神经障碍，它
can present very similar to Tourette's in terms of what might be going on for somebody. The bits that make it quite tricky though is then how long has this been going on? So did it start in childhood? Whereas typically for functional neurological disorder it didn't start in childhood. Not saying it can't but often something happened and since this event these behaviours have now been present and the other difficult one on that is you can also have both. So you could have Tourette's, and functional and logical disorders at times of things really. I think in terms of the pregnancy side of stuff, we, I don't think we've had anybody that's come through our clinic
在表现上可能与妥瑞氏症非常相似。让它变得相当棘手的部分是，这已经持续多久了？所以它是在童年时期开始的吗？而通常对于功能性神经障碍，它不是在童年时期开始的。不是说它不能，但通常发生了一些事情，从这个事件开始，这些行为现在已经存在了，而另一个困难的是，你也可以两者兼有。所以你可能患有妥瑞氏症，有时还有功能性神经障碍。我认为在怀孕方面，我们，我不认为我们有任何怀孕的妥瑞氏症患者来到我们的诊所。
who has been pregnant with Tourette. We've had clients who've had some very painful and some very difficult ticks in terms of their motor actions, self-hitting themselves, lots of pain, so almost like a lock-in so they can't move physically. It's almost freezing in place. Those have been quite painful ones really. So there's some element of that sometimes that occurs for people really.
我们有客户在运动动作方面有一些非常痛苦和非常困难的抽动，比如自残，很多疼痛，所以几乎像是一种锁定，所以他们不能在身体上移动。几乎是冻结在原地。那些确实是非常痛苦的。所以有时人们确实会发生这种情况。
Okay, so given that obviously this can be quite a complicated diagnosis process and that sometimes it might look a bit like something else, is there anything else that you kind of need to rule in or rule out before you go, with a Tourette's diagnosis, Jason? Yes, yeah. So I think when you look at the diagnostic criteria, the bottom part of Part 4 in terms of that is it's not better explained by something else. So there are some physical health conditions that look like it could be Tourette's,
好的，鉴于这显然是一个相当复杂的诊断过程，而且有时它看起来有点像其他疾病，在做出妥瑞氏症诊断之前，Jason，你还需要排除或确认其他什么吗？是的，没错。我认为当你查看诊断标准时，第4部分的后半部分是指它不能用其他原因来更好地解释。所以确实有一些身体健康状况看起来可能像妥瑞氏症，
but might be something else. So for example, Huntingdon's in terms of that. So where we try to do then is if it comes through as an adult referral and it's come via GP, sometimes it comes other areas, but primarily it's GPs. We might ask the GP to refer on to neurology first just to rule out any physical calls for what might be going on.
但实际上可能是其他疾病。例如，亨廷顿舞蹈症就是这样。所以我们尝试做的是，如果是通过全科医生（GP）转诊的成年患者，有时也会通过其他渠道，但主要是全科医生。我们可能会要求全科医生先转诊到神经科，以排除任何可能导致这些症状的身体原因。
Similarly, if from looking at the referral, it seems to not have had a childhood start, but may have started in adulthood after something. It might be there's an functional neurological disorder element or FND part to it as well. So that's why we might ask GPs to refer to neurology just to give them a physical health once over really to sort of rule out, okay, we don't think there's a physical basis for this.
同样，如果从转诊信息来看，症状似乎并非始于童年，而是在成年后因某事引发的，那么其中可能还包含功能性神经障碍（FND）的成分。这就是为什么我们可能会要求全科医生转诊到神经科，让他们进行一次全面的身体检查，以排除我们认为这并非由身体疾病引起的情况。
And then often they then sort of get referred back to us for the assessment side of things potentially. Yeah, thank you. And sometimes people are hitting their own heads and stuff and they kind of can't do that. And I think that can be scary for people at times. And knowing whether you should be trying to restrain someone or support them in that capacity, Is there a general rule of thumb? Like what ought we be doing if someone is ticking and at risk of hurting themselves, Jason?
然后他们通常会被转回给我们进行评估。是的，谢谢。有时人们会撞击自己的头部之类的，他们自己也无法控制。我认为这有时会让人们感到害怕。对于是否应该尝试约束某人或在那种情况下支持他们，有没有通用的经验法则？Jason，如果有人正在抽动且有伤害自己的风险，我们应该怎么做？
Yeah. I think with the extreme in terms of causing harm to themselves in terms of that bit, where we've tended to suggest to people around that is, unfortunately, it does vary. For some people, if it is more likely to be behaviour that's linked with Tourette's, So a motor tick that's going on, it can be about helping to reduce the likelihood of being in a situation where that is going to happen.
是的。我认为对于造成自我伤害的极端情况，我们倾向于建议周围的人，不幸的是，这确实因人而异。对于某些人来说，如果这更像是与妥瑞氏症相关的行为，即正在发生的运动抽动，那么关键在于帮助减少发生这种情况的可能性。
So sometimes it can be where somebody is punching themselves, for example, or hitting their head with something. Sometimes it can be about, okay, how do we support that person to not hurt themselves? is it around wearing something protective? So they're actually not hurt themselves or do we give them something soft to hold? So maybe potentially it's around they're using that to hit themselves rather than a closed hand or a fist or things like that for when hitting themselves really.
所以有时，例如某人正在打自己或用东西撞头。有时关键在于，好吧，我们如何支持那个人不伤害自己？是佩戴某种保护装置吗？这样他们就不会真的伤害到自己，或者我们给他们一些柔软的东西拿着？这样他们可能会用那个东西来打自己，而不是用紧握的手或拳头之类的来打自己。
But it's a really difficult or can be a really difficult. I think the proportion of people across Tourette's who have that does tend to be much smaller. And often when it's at that level or that extreme, that's sometimes where it might be actually, maybe medication might be something that they might want to then look at and explore. Although, as we've said, there isn't really a medication to help manage that. But some of the medications can be used to help make people help them feel more relaxed and therefore they're less likely to express their Tourette's.
但这确实非常困难，或者说可能非常困难。我认为在妥瑞氏症患者中，出现这种情况的比例往往要小得多。通常当达到那种程度或极端情况时，有时可能确实需要考虑并探索药物治疗。尽管正如我们所说，并没有真正能帮助控制这种情况的药物。但有些药物可以用来帮助人们放松，从而降低他们表现出妥瑞氏症症状的可能性。
But unfortunately, there isn't consistent medication that's going to help them completely. cut it out. And as I said, the European guidelines would often go with behavioural interventions and are more likely to have a beneficial outcome in terms of helping reduce, and particularly those sort of harmful ticks that might be causing pain for people. Yeah, and we're recording this on the day in the UK where it's been announced that has been a lupus trial, which has been successful in mitigating people's symptoms of lupus. I would love it if in future we were able to maybe say the same about medication or treatment for Tourette's that actually did almost stop it in its tracks and made life much more manageable for people.
但不幸的是，没有持续有效的药物能完全消除它。正如我所说，欧洲指南通常会建议行为干预，这更有可能在帮助减少症状方面产生有益的结果，特别是那些可能给人们带来痛苦的有害抽动。是的，我们录制这一集的当天，英国宣布了一项红斑狼疮试验，该试验在减轻患者症状方面取得了成功。如果未来我们也能对妥瑞氏症的药物或治疗说同样的话，即它能真正阻止症状发展，并让人们的生活变得更容易管理，那该多好。
Well, as you said, there is a, so at the moment, so I mentioned about the technology appraisal stuff before. So there is a, and I'm not advocating this at the moment because it hasn't gone through the nice guidelines and it's not been approved. But they are looking at a wearable technology that at the moment does seem to be, have a good starting research base in terms of evidence that's been really helpful in terms of hugely helping reduce the amount of tick-like behaviour that somebody might be expressing really. I think NICE is still exploring and still doing their appraisal bits at the moment, but if it is as effective as obviously it's a private company, so they say they're the best things slice bread, but if the evidence can back up their claims, then yes, definitely, I think this
嗯，正如你所说，目前确实有，我之前提到了技术评估。所以目前有一个，我并不是在此时此刻提倡它，因为它还没有通过NICE指南，也没有获得批准。但他们正在研究一种可穿戴技术，目前看来，它在研究基础方面似乎有很好的证据支持，在极大程度上帮助减少了某人可能表现出的抽动样行为。我认为NICE目前仍在探索和评估中，但如果它确实像他们说的那样有效——当然这是一家私营公司，所以他们自夸是最好的东西——但如果证据能支持他们的说法，那么是的，绝对，我认为这
could be a really important, almost game-changing moment, I think, for people who are experiencing Tourette's because they're able to have a wearable technology that can help them significantly reduce when they might be expressing those tick behaviour and how much control they can then have over when they might be expressing what's going on for them. That's fascinating stuff and I watched a video of someone, I think of with Parkinson's, either wearing this bit of, obviously a different bit of kit, but wearing the watch or the wearable and not wearing the watch. And I think they were making a cup of tea in both examples. And it was, you know, poles apart.
可能是一个非常重要的、几乎是改变游戏规则的时刻，我认为，对于那些经历妥瑞氏症的人来说，因为他们能够拥有一种可穿戴技术，可以帮助他们显著减少表现出抽动行为的时间，并让他们对自己正在经历的事情有更多的控制权。这太令人着迷了，我看过一个视频，是一个患有帕金森病的人，戴着这个设备——当然是不同的设备——但戴着手表或可穿戴设备和不戴手表时的对比。我想他们在两个例子中都在泡茶。那真是天壤之别。
When they're wearing the tech, they wouldn't, you wouldn't have known that this person had Parkinson's diagnosis. And I would hope that this, whatever this device does, whether it's biofeedback, whether it's some sort of stimulation, I hope that it does really, work for people so that they can kind of step out from the identity of Tourette's because I think it can it can kind of put a bit of a cloud and I think the two the person and the diagnosis become quite enmeshed I think don't they yeah definitely and I think that's where that sort of myths bit comes in particular and if you know anyone is particularly interested around some of
当他们戴着这项技术时，你根本看不出这个人患有帕金森病。我希望这个设备，无论它是生物反馈还是某种刺激，我希望它真的能对人们有效，这样他们就可以从妥瑞氏症的身份中走出来，因为我认为这会蒙上一层阴影，而且我认为患者本人和诊断结果变得非常纠缠在一起，不是吗？是的，绝对是这样，我认为这就是那些误区特别突出的地方，如果你知道有人对其中一些
those myths Tourette's action has I said a huge amount of useful information and resorts on there. I think they've even got like a leaflet of the 10 top myths for Tourette's in terms of that bit, one of which is everybody with Tourette swears a lot and actually 95% of people with threats don't swear at all. It's a very tiny percentage, but it's things like that. But I think where that's really helpful in terms of is helping people get a better understanding. And I think whether the wearable tech, from what I've seen so far, could really helpful in terms of helping bring down really severe expressions of ticks and Tourette's really to a point where somebody then can help them to better understand what's going on. And once they know that there is possible to reduce the ticks and Tourette's,
误区特别感兴趣，妥瑞氏症行动组织（Tourette's Action）正如我所说，有大量有用的信息和资源。我想他们甚至有一份关于妥瑞氏症十大误区的传单，其中之一是“每个妥瑞氏症患者都会频繁骂人”，而实际上95%的妥瑞氏症患者根本不会骂人。这只是极小的一部分，但就是这类事情。但我认为这在帮助人们更好地理解方面非常有帮助。而且我认为，从我目前所见，可穿戴技术在帮助减少妥瑞氏症非常严重的抽动表现方面确实非常有帮助，直到某人能够更好地理解正在发生的事情。一旦他们知道减少抽动和妥瑞氏症是可能的，
for me, obviously being a psychologist, I might help the behavioral side of things as well, really. So they maybe not necessarily have to be completely reliant on tech or the technology, but they could have a balance between the two. So I know the battery goes and you're out and about and you can't get it be charged. Yeah, there's things like that. Or unless the NHS is going to pay for it, and therefore you can get it on prescription, you can have to buy it and it's unlikely to be cheap.
对我来说，作为一名心理学家，我也可以帮助处理行为方面的问题。所以他们不一定非要完全依赖技术，但他们可以在两者之间取得平衡。因为我知道电池会没电，当你出门在外时，你无法给它充电。是的，有这样的事情。或者除非英国国家医疗服务体系（NHS）愿意支付费用，从而你可以凭处方获得它，否则你必须自己购买，而且它不太可能便宜。
Yeah. Or it's not like to be as cheap as getting it on prescription. It's probably the best right of selling it. So again, you then have a two-tier. You can afford it. You can get the treatment. You can't. I would say I would hope that the battery life is more akin to my old Fitbit
是的。或者它不像凭处方获得那样便宜。这可能是最好的销售方式。所以同样，你又会面临双重标准。如果你负担得起，你就能得到治疗。如果你负担不起，就不能。我会说我希望电池寿命更像我旧的Fitbit
and less like my Apple watch. my Apple Watch. Yes. Terrible. It's shocking. It's like, oh, this episode is not sponsored by Apple Watches. What a lovely place to leave this on. Thank you so much for being so generous with your time and thank you for your trust for
而不是像我的Apple Watch。我的Apple Watch。是的。太糟糕了。这太令人震惊了。哦，本集节目不由Apple Watch赞助。这是一个多么可爱的结束点。非常感谢你如此慷慨地贡献你的时间，也感谢你的信任，
putting us in touch as well. Is there anywhere you would want people to come along and follow the trust or learn more about you and your work, Jason? Yeah. So yeah, so they can obviously follow us online. We've got the Northamptonshire Healthcare and I think we were recently in the news because we're one of the first, I can't think what's called now, I think accelerated trusts. So we've got more control over our budget about how we can use the money at the moment in terms of that bit.
让我们建立联系。Jason，你希望人们去哪里关注该信托基金或了解更多关于你和你的工作的信息吗？是的，他们当然可以在线关注我们。我们有北安普敦郡医疗保健信托基金（Northamptonshire Healthcare），我想我们最近上了新闻，因为我们是第一批，我不记得现在叫什么了，我想是加速信托基金。所以我们目前在如何使用资金方面有更多的控制权。
For our team, I said of working the adult ADHD, awesome and Tourette service, I think. Thank you so much again. And yeah, thanks for illuminating myself and our audience about this really important work that you do. Yeah, that's what I thank you. Thank you so much for watching and what an absolute pleasure it was to speak with Jason. I also really want to thank the cons team at the NHS Trust that Jason works for. They were so kind to me they even sent a little good luck message today and they sent me some information about the trust so I really like to share that with you. In Northamptonshire Healthcare NHS Foundation Trust, NHFT, we provide over 200 services across Northamptonshire and some specialist services in nearby areas. Working close to
对于我们的团队，我负责成人多动症（ADHD）、自闭症和妥瑞氏症服务，我想就是这样。再次非常感谢。是的，感谢你让我和我们的听众了解了你所做的这项非常重要的工作。是的，这就是我要说的，谢谢。非常感谢大家的观看，与Jason交谈绝对是一种荣幸。我也非常感谢Jason工作的NHS信托基金的公关团队。他们对我非常友善，今天甚至发来了一条小小的祝好运的信息，还发给我一些关于信托基金的信息，所以我真的很想与大家分享。在北安普敦郡医疗保健NHS基金会信托（NHFT），我们在北安普敦郡提供200多项服务，并在附近地区提供一些专业服务。与我们的合作伙伴密切合作，
with our partners, we make sure that everyone who uses our services receives caring, personalised treatment, no matter their background or situation. We employ around 5,500 dedicated staff who work hard to care for people in many ways. They work in hospitals, clinics, schools, workplaces, prisons, and visit people at home or out in the community. Whether on the front line or in support roles, everyone plays an important part in helping others. And thank you so much to the Trust for allowing Jason to speak with us in his work time. Has this been a useful watch or listen to you? I do hope so. If you're not already a follower of the show, wherever you listen to your MP3 podcast, please do take a moment
我们确保每一位使用我们服务的人都能得到关怀、个性化的治疗，无论他们的背景或处境如何。我们雇佣了大约5500名敬业的员工，他们努力以多种方式照顾人们。他们在医院、诊所、学校、工作场所、监狱工作，并到人们家中或社区进行探访。无论是在一线还是在支持岗位，每个人在帮助他人方面都发挥着重要作用。非常感谢信托基金允许Jason在工作时间与我们交谈。这对你来说是一次有用的观看或收听吗？我真心希望如此。如果你还没有关注这个节目，无论你在哪里收听你的MP3播客，请花点时间
to follow psychology actually right now. It really does help the show to grow and helps me to ensure that I can keep creating content that you find really helpful. And if you are watching on YouTube, please take a moment to subscribe, maybe hit that notification bell too, so you never miss another episode. Don't forget that we now have two episodes a week. We have our main episode which comes out on Saturdays or Mondays and then we've got an episode that comes out on Wednesday evenings. They're called Inner Work and they are now entirely free. I thought the content was too good not to share with you. So do take a listen, take a watch and I would love your thoughts. Please do like, please do comment. Please do help that.
立即关注《心理学实际上》（Psychology Actually）。这确实有助于节目的成长，并帮助我确保能够持续创作你觉得真正有用的内容。如果你正在YouTube上观看，请花点时间订阅，也许还可以点击那个通知铃铛，这样你就不会错过任何一集。别忘了我们现在每周有两集节目。我们有在周六或周一发布的主集，然后我们在周三晚上还有一集。它们被称为“内在工作”（Inner Work），现在完全免费。我觉得内容太好了，不能不与你分享。所以请收听、观看，我很想听听你的想法。请点赞，请评论。请帮助那个
show to grow as well. If you've enjoyed this episode, I think you might also really enjoy the episode I did with Sky Hewitt, who is a trainee clinical psychologist who's registered blind and has a guide dog. It's such a privilege to speak with her. I think you'll love that one too. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
节目也成长起来。如果你喜欢这一集，我想你可能也会非常喜欢我与Sky Hewitt做的那一集，她是一位注册盲人并拥有导盲犬的临床心理学实习生。能与她交谈真是太荣幸了。我想你也会喜欢那一集的。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。